there's a big difference of getting off  of steroids and stop drinking alcohol or  stop smoking weed you get off of wheat  okay maybe you're gonna chew or smoke  cigars or something that you're  replacing it with there is no replacing  growth hormone and steroids with  something else that's gonna fill the  need in your body that's not because  wheat is not dramatically you know or  this is my thing you get what I'm saying  maybe I'm wrong about this but I'm  convinced that it's my obsession with  over training that's that's screwing up  my hormones you know that that I think  that if if I can fix away and find a way  to not have to do this two or three  times a day and just do it at least once  a day I think if I do it once a day get  into the gym at least once a day and not  do two or three times a day  um I think because over training clearly  has an effect on your hormone profile